used by best before
if you've ever been confused by all the
different language around expiry dates
on food you're not alone
eu citizens waste 88 million tons of
food every year
up to 10 of that is because date
labeling is misunderstood
logically then if more of us understood
the date marking we would throw away
less food every year
in fact up to 8 million tons less
when you buy a food product at a
supermarket you're going to see a range
of mandatory information on the
packaging nutritional information
ingredients and a bunch of different
dates
used by and best before are the most
common ones
so what do they mean
let's break it down starting with you
spy
in a 2015 study the european union asked
europeans if they knew what u-spy stands
for more than half got it wrong
the job of the use by label is to tell
you until when a food product can be
eaten without any risk to your health
it is mandatory for perishable foods
such as meat fish and some types of
cheese
so if you see this it means you can eat
the food until the end of this date but
not after
even if you think it looks and smells
fine
now best before tells you about the
quality of the food product
it means that it's perfectly fine to eat
a product after this date but it may no
longer be at its best quality and could
have lost some of its optimal flavor and
texture so if you see this it means you
are to judge for yourself if you want to
eat the food depending on its appearance
and smell
so to recap use pie is about food safety
best before has to do with food quality
those are the basics
now there are a few notes
not all the food we eat requires day
marking
uncut fresh fruit and vegetables for
instance
here no use buy or best before dates are
required
also date marking only works when
storage instructions for a food product
are respected and if the packaging isn't
damaged
a use by date on a raw stake for example
won't be any good if it's been left
outside on a warm day
on the other hand you can extend the
shelf 5 of a product beyond the use by
date by freezing it right after you buy
it
you do have to make sure it's frozen at
the right temperature packaged well kept
away from any contaminants and that it
has not been frozen before
finally you absolutely have to make sure
you follow instructions on consumption
such as consume within two days of
opening
households are responsible for more than
half of europe's food waste so a big
chunk of the responsibility is not up to
supermarkets or governments or
restaurants
it is up to us
we have a big power departures power to
choose what
we
buy and of course how we use
store
refrigerate cook
the food items
european union regulators understand
that date labeling on food products
isn't always easy to understand
so they're planning on reviewing the
rules by the end of 2022 the confusion
with date marking is sometimes linked to
translation in some languages the
difference between use by and best
before
seems not be clear enough
so what is missing
i would say all over the world not only
in europe we need to invest more on food
education basics
and then everything will be more clear
and
waste will be reduced
for now though the best we can do is
learn to read labels properly
by doing that we would not only help
reduce food waste but also fight climate
change because we'd save natural
resources spend less money at the
supermarket and make healthier food
choices
and there's no expiry date for those
things